the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu ok so today is the last
lecture day we're going to talk about
draw architecture this is a processor
that was built here at MIT and
essentially trailblaze a lot of the
research in terms of parallel
architectures for multicores compilation
for multicores programming language and
so on so you've heard some things about
raw and the paralyzing technology in
terms of stream it I'm going to cover
some of that again here today just
briefly and give you a little bit more
insight into what women when what went
into the design of the raw architecture
so these are raw ships that were
delivered in October of 2002 each one of
these has 16 processors on it I'm going
to show you a trivet diagram on the next
slide it's really a tiled microprocessor
we'll get into what that means and how
it actually what is what does a tile
throughout microprocessor give you that
makes it an attractive design point in
architecture space each of the raw tiles
you sort of see the outline here sort of
replicates as four millimeters it's a
four millimeter squared it's a single
issue 8 stage pipeline it has local
memory so sorry to K cash and the unique
aspect of the raw processor is that has
a lot of on-chip networks that you can
use to orchestrate communication between
processors so there's two operon
networks I'm going to get into what that
means and what they're used for but
these essentially allow you to do
point-to-point communication between
tiles with very low latency and then
there's a network that essentially
allows you to handle cache misses and
input and output and 14 message passing
for more dynamic style messaging
something similar to what you're
accustomed to with the cell for example
in DMA transfers this was built in 180
nanometer ASIC technology by IBM it's
got a hundred million
sisters it was designed here by MIT grad
students it's got something like a
million gates on it three to four years
of development times and it was really
interesting here is that this was
because of the tiled nature of the
architecture you can just design one
tile and then once you have one tile in
central just plop down more and more and
more of them and so you have one you
scale it after 16 tiles design sort of
came back without any bugs when it was
when the first chip was delivered core
frequency was expected to run at 425 I
think lower than 425 megahertz to 50
megahertz and came back and ran to 425
megahertz and it's been clocked as high
as 500 megahertz at 2.2 volts had the
chip isn't really designed for low power
but the tile abstraction is really nice
for power consumption because if you're
not using tiles you can essentially just
shut them down so it allows you to sort
of have power efficient design just by
nature of the architecture but when
you're using all tiles all the memories
all the networks in a non sort of
optimized design you consume about 18
watts of power so what's a you know how
do you use this tile processor so here's
one particular example the nice thing
about Kyle architecture is that you can
let applications consume as many tiles
as they need you know if you have not an
application with a lot of parallelism
then you give it a lot of tiles if you
have an application doesn't need a lot
of parallelism then if you don't give it
a lot of tiles so it allows you to
really exploit sort of the mapping of
your application down to the
architecture and gives you a sick like
behavior application-specific processing
technology so you know one example is
you have some video that you're
recording and you want to encode it and
you know stream across the web or
display it on your monitor or whatever
else so you can have some logic that you
map down your chips are here you do some
computation you have memories sprinkled
across the tile that you're going to use
for local local store so you can do you
can paralyze for example emotion
compensate the motion estimation for
encoding the temporal technology
temporal we're done
see in a video stream you can have
another application completely
independent running on another part of
the chip so here's an application it's
using four different tiles and it's
really isolated doesn't affect what's
going on in these tiles you can have
another application that's running
something like MPI where you doing
dynamic messaging httpd server and this
tiles maybe not used as just sleeping or
it's idle you can have memories
connected off the chip io devices so
it's really interesting in incense
probably the most interesting aspect of
it is a lot of tiles to sort of be used
as the fundamental resource and you can
scale them up as your application
parallelism scales this is picture of
the raw board draw a motherboard that's
actually you can see it in Stata Center
in the raw lab this is the raw chip a
lot of the peripheral device firmware
and interconnect you're dealing with a
lot of devices off the chill off the
chip are implemented in these FPGA so
users I links chips there's DRAM you
have connection to a pci pci card USB
stick a network interface so you can
actually log into this machine and use
it it it can and there's a sort of real
compiler can run real applications on it
there's actually a bigger tip that we've
built where we take four of these raw
chips and sort of scale them up so you
can have rather than having 16 tiles on
your motherboard you can have for raw
chips that gives you 60 for tiles you
can scale this up to a thousand tiles or
so on just because of the tile nature
everything is symmetric homogeneous you
can really scale it up really really big
so what is the performance of raw so
looking at the sort of overall
application performance so we've done a
lot of benchmarking so these are from
numbers from a paper that was published
in 2004 where we took a lot of
applications summer well-known used in
standard benchmark suites and sort of
compile them for raw using various rock
compiler that we built in-house and
we've compared them against the pentium
3 so the pentium 3 is sort of a unique
comparison point because it sort of
matches raw in terms of the technology
that was used to fabricate the two and
what you're seeing here this is a
scale the speed up of the application
running on raw compared to the
application running on a p3 so the
higher you get the better the
performance is so these applications
sort of grouped into a few classes so
the first class is what we call ILP
applications so these are applications
that have essentially instruction level
parallelism I'm going to talk a little
bit more about that and sort of explain
it but you've seen this early on lecture
and some of Simone's lectures so here
you're trying to exploit sort of
inherent instruction level parallelism
in your applications and if you have
lots of ILP then you map it to a lot of
tiles and you can get parallelism that
way and you get better performance these
applications here what we call the
streaming application so you saw some of
these mistreatment lecture and the
paralyzed the stream it parallelizing
compiler some of those numbers were
generated on a roll like architecture
and then you have the server or sort of
more traditional applications that you
expect to run in a server style or
throughput oriented and then finally you
have bit level applications so doing
things that vary at that the lowest
level of computation where you're doing
a lot of bit manipulation so but you're
you know what's interesting here to note
is that as you get into more
applications that have a lot of inherent
parallelism in them where you want
explicit so where you can extract a lot
of parallelism because of the explicit
nature of the applications you can
really map those really well to the
architecture and because of the
communication nature because of
communication capabilities of the
architecture being able to stream data
from one tile to another really fast you
can get really really high on Japan
which and that gives you really high
performance especially for these kinds
of applications there are other
applications that we've done some of the
students have worked on in the raw group
so an mpeg-2 encoder where you're
essentially trying to do real-time
encoding of a video stream a different
resolution so 350 x 240 or 720 x 480
where you're compiling down to the
number of tiles you know one four eight
sixteen sorry one is 16
using natural rights and what you're
looking for here sort of scalability of
your algorithm as you add more tiles are
you getting more and more performance or
are you getting better and better
throughput so you can include more
frames per second for example and so if
you're doing HDTV it's 1080p then you
really want to sort of get there's a lot
of compute power that you need and so as
you had more friends maybe you can get
to sort of the throughput that you need
for HDTV and so this is something that
might be interesting for some of your
project as well and we've talked about
this before you know on the cell as
using more and more sbes can you sort of
accelerate the performance of your
application you sort of show that if
you're doing some visual aspects you can
sort of demonstrate it so there's a demo
that is set up in in the lab where you
can sort of crank up the number of tiles
that you're using and you get better
performance from the MPEG encoder and
looking at the number of frames per
second that you can get you know it's
with 64 tiles so the raw chip is 16 file
but you can sort of scale it up by
having more chips so you can get about
51 frames these numbers have been
improved and there are different ways of
so optimizing these performances I you
know 352 x 48 x 2 80 x 240 in an
estimated data rate estimated to go to
100 60 frames per second almost so this
is really high bandwidth another
interesting thing that we've done with
the raw chip is taking a look at
graphics pipelines and looking at is
there anything we can do to exploit sort
of the inherent tiled architecture of
draw chip so here's a screenshot from
counter-strike and simplify a graphics
pipeline where you have some input to
the screen you want to render you do
some vertex shading so these are
triangles that you want to sort of
figure out what colors to make a close
to paint them triangle set up for pixel
stage and in this screen you'll notice
that there are two different things that
you're rendering there's such as this
part of screen which has a lot of
triangles that's pan relatively not so
complex image and then you have these
guys here that have fewer triangles span
a smaller region of the of the of the
frame and what you might want to do is
allocate more compute power to the pixel
stage and let's compute power to the
vertex stage so that's analogous to
saying I want more tiles for one stage
of pipeline and fewer tiles for another
or maybe I want to be able to sort of
dynamically change how many tiles I'm
allocating a different stages of the
pipeline so there as your as your
screens that you're rendering change in
terms of their complexity you can have
you know you can maintain sort of the
good visual illusions transparently
without sort of compromising a lot of
the utilization of the chip so some
demos that were done with the graphics
group at MIT fridge or dorians group you
know funk shading you have 132 vertices
one light source you know so this is
what you're trying to shade you have a
lot of regions black so if you're
looking at a fixed pipeline where you
know the vertex shader is taking six
tiles this is on a 64 file chip the
rasterizer is taking 15 tiles the pixel
processor has 15 tiles the output buffer
operations have 15 tiles then you might
not sort of get the best utilization
because for that entire region that
you're rendering where it's black or
there's nothing to really nothing really
interesting happening there you want to
shift those tiles to another processor
to another stage at a pipeline or if you
can't really utilize them then you're
just wasting power you're wasting energy
and so you might just want to flip them
down use them at all so with a fixed
pipeline versus a reconfigurable
pipeline where I can sort of change the
number of piles allocated is two
different stages of a pipeline I can get
better utilization and in some cases at
our performance so here shorter bars I
mean you're finishing faster and time so
this is sort of indicative also what's
going on graphics industry so the
graphics cards used to be very model
very well yet fixed resources allocated
different stage which is essentially
what we're trying to model in this part
of the experiment where more and more
now you have sort of unified shaders
that you can use further pixel shading
in the vertex shading so you're getting
into more that programmable
precisely because you want to be able to
sort of do this kind of load balancing
and exploits or dynamism that you see
different frames that you're trying to
render another example you know shadow
volumes you have four triangles want one
light source you can and this was
rendered in three passes so you know
pass one pass to pass three what
essentially takes the amount of time
because you're doing same computation
map to fix number of resources but if I
can change the number of resources that
I need for different passes so the
rasterizer for example in the output
buffer operations is really where you
need a lot of power so if you go from 15
files for each 225 for each you get
better execution time because you're
able to exploit parallelism or match
house and better to the application and
so you get forty percent faster in this
particular case and another interesting
application this is the largest in the
world microphone right it's actually in
the Guinness Book of Records it was
built in the lab and what essentially
has each of these little boards has two
microphones on it and so you can use
this for is eavesdropping for example or
you can you know carry this around if
you want packing the car and do some
spying but someone more interesting
memos that were or that we're done with
this and smaller scales with in a noisy
room for example if you want to sort of
hone in let's say everybody here was
speaking but for the camera they want to
sort of record only my voice they can
have a microphone array in the back that
sort of focuses on just my voice and the
way it's done is you can measure serve
the distance from the time it takes for
the same way through these different
microphones you can sort of focus in on
particular source of noise and be able
to just highlight that so you can so
there's this demo where it's a noisy
room I probably should have had these in
here in retrospect there's a noisy room
lots of people are talking then you turn
on the microphone array and you can sort
of hear that one particular source and
so luck there you can also have
applications where you're tracking
person in
in in room with video as well so you can
sort of follow him around so it's very
interesting application and now I regret
not having that video demo here actually
should I do it it's on the waiver okay
so case study using the beamformer so
what's not what's being done in the
microphone array is you're doing
beamforming so you're trying to figure
out what are different beams are
reaching microphone you want to be able
to sort of amplify one of them so
looking at the application running
written written natively and see running
on one gives pentium 3 what is the
operation throughput so you're getting
about 240 mega flops and if you go down
to and optimize to optimize same code
but running on a single tile raw chip
you get about 19 by default so not very
good performance but here what you
really want to do is you have a lot of
parallelism because each of those games
that's reaching users with microphones
can be done in parallel so you have a
lot of parallels in that application so
taking the sea program we implement the
instrument that you've seen in previous
lectures and not really optimizing it in
terms of doing a lot of the
optimizations you saw in in the
paralyzing compiler talk you get about
640 mega flops so already you're being
sort of the sea program running on
pretty fast a superscalar machine and if
you really optimize the streamit code in
terms of doing the fission and fusion
yep increasing sort of parallelism doing
better load balancing automatically you
can get up to 1.4 gigaflops so really
good performance and really matching the
inherent parallelism to the architecture
okay so it was just a brief overview of
the raw chip and what we've done with in
lab there's more in here that I've
talked about but what I'm going to do
next to sort of give you some insights
as to what is the design philosophy that
went to raw architectures of why is it
why was it designed the way it was and
then I'm going to talk a little bit
about the raw paralyzing compiler and
I'm not while the streamit language and
compiler also has a back end for the raw
architecture we've sort of seen that
previous lecture so I'm not going to
talk about that here so I'm just going
to focus on the first two bullets
and you know a few years ago when sort
of the project got started sort of the
insight that in the idea why issue
processors and sort of the design
philosophy that was being followed in
industry for building wider super
scalars faster super scalars was really
going to come to a halt largely because
you have scalability issues so if you
look at to simplify the stray shin of a
white issue microprocessor you have your
program counter fetches instructions
goes into some control logic control
logic is then going to run you're going
to read some variables from the register
file you know you have big cross bar in
the middle it routes two operands to
write al use and then you operate on
those and you have to send data back to
register file plus you have this really
big problem with the network so if
you're doing some computation oh sorry
this Ouija slides so you have if you
have n al use then the complexity of
your crossbar increases as N squared
because you essentially have to have
everybody talking to each other and in
terms of the number of wires that need
at a register file to support everybody
being able to sort of talk to anybody
else very efficiently the number of
ports number of wires increases and cube
so that's a problem because you're you
can't clock all those wires fast enough
the frequency becomes sort of limited it
grows even less than linearly and this
is a problem because operationally
routing opera and routing is global so
if I have you know I'm doing some
operation it's an ad the results of this
ad is fed to another operation a shift
and these are going to execute on two
different al use so what's going to
happen I do the add operation it's going
to produce a result but there is no
direct path for this ALU to send its
result of this ALU so instead what has
to happen is the Opera has to travel all
the way back around through the crossbar
and then back to this ALU and so that's
really that's going to take a long time
and not necessarily very efficient and
if you're doing this for a lot of ALU
operations you have a lot of parallelism
in your application a lot of instruction
level parallelism and that's just
creating a lot of communication but
you're not really exploiting the
locality of the
application you know if two instructions
are really close together you want to be
able to just have a point-to-point path
for example or a shorter path that
allows you to sort of exploit where
those instructions are in space and so
this was sort of the driving inside for
the architecture and that you want make
you want to make opera and rowdy local
so an idea is to essentially exploit
this locality by distributing the AL use
and rather than having that massive
crossbar what you want to do is have an
on-chip mesh network so rather than
having one big crossbar you have lots of
smaller ones so these become switch
processors so i can put value from this
ALU here and then have that value routed
to any other ALU maybe that just cost me
more in terms of instructions that says
where it is up where this operand is
going so we'll get into that but here
what this allows me to do is exploit
that locality better same instructions
chain I can put the AL the first
operation on one al you can put the
other operation on the second day lu and
here rather than putting it for example
here which would send the operand really
far across a chip what I want to do is
recognize that there's a producer
consumer relationship here I want to
exploit that locality and have them
close in space so that the rats remain
fairly short and then what I can also do
a sort of pipeline this network so that
I can have the hardware essentially
match computation flow if one ALU is
producing a lot of results a lot at a
lot faster rate than for example is
instruction can consume them then the
hardware can sort of take care for
example of blocking or stalling me the
producing processor so it doesn't get
too far ahead it gives you a sort of a
natural mechanism for regulating the
flow of data on the chip well this is
better than sort of what we saw before
because with the crossbar you're not
really getting any scalability in terms
of your latency to transport operands
from one al you to another whereas with
on-chip network if you've taken sort of
writing classes you know that there
exists an algorithm that sort of allows
you to write things at least square root
of n where n is the number of things
that are communicating on your network
but if you're doing locality driven
basement and it's essentially constant
time Anna rawtube it's in fact three
cycles so you can send one operand from
one tile to another in three cycles and
get into how that number comes about
this is much better but what it does is
increase the complexity on the compiler
it says this is my computation how do
you map it efficiently so that things
are clustered in space well so that I'm
not I don't have these really long locks
routes for communication but then we can
look at what else can we distribute well
we have the eight we have the register
file we can distribute that across all
the AL use and that essentially
decreases that n cubed relationship
between Al use and register file ports
to something that's a lot more tractable
where it's one small register file for
ALU and this is better in terms of
scalability but we have installed the
entire problem now we still have one
global program counter we have one
global instruction fetch unit one global
control you know unified load/store
queue for communicating with memory and
those all have Q scalability problems so
whereas we fixed a problem with the
crossbar that becomes more scalable we
haven't really fixed the problems with
the other so what's the natural solution
to do here well we'll just distribute
everything else ever and so you start
off with each al you here now having its
own program counter its own instruction
cache its own data cache and it has this
register file ALU and everybody that
seemed sort of design pattern is
repeated for each one of those al use so
now it looks like it's a lot more
scalable I don't have any global wires
there's no global centralized data
structure and all of that means I can do
things more I can do things faster more
efficiently and what you start seeing
here is this sort of tiled processor
coming about so all each one of those
things was exactly the scene and what
was done in the raw processor is that
none of those tiles was longer than you
can communicate in one clock cycle so
this solves essentially required to lay
problem as well so if this is the
distance that a wire that a signal can
travel in one clock cycle we serve the
tile is smaller
it can fit within this circle so that
means that you guaranteed you have
better scalability problems in solving
sort of the issues that people are
facing with why delay and in terms of
sort of the tile processor abstraction
Michael Taylor was a PhD student in the
raw group his thesis sort of identified
the pilot processor approach and this
aspect of the tile processor approached
it makes it more attractive the Sun
which is the scalar operand network and
the sort of next few slides next part of
the lecture is going to really focus on
what that means instead of argues why
the pilot processor approach is scalable
and scalable for same reasons multicores
you just add more more cores on a chip
but the entrant the the intrinsic
difference between sort of the
multi-core is that you see today and
they're all architecture is the scale
operant network so as you questions
about this is a few slides but really
what you're getting here is the ability
to serve communicate from one processor
to another very efficiently and the way
you do this on Raw is you know you have
your instruction fetch decode register
file reach stage wal you you're a
computation pipeline but part of the
registers in your register file so 24 to
27 our network map so what that means is
if I right if one of the operations that
I have in my computation has a
destination register that's 24 25 26 or
27 that value automatically gets sent to
the output network and if I have a value
if one of my source operands is
registered 24 25 26 27 so implicitly
that means get that value off the
network and so I can have you know add
25 to add into register 25 so this is
one of the network map ports some two
operands so this is a picture of the raw
chip this is one tile this is the other
tile so you sort of see the computation
and the network switch processor here so
the operand flows into the network
and it gets transported across from one
tile to the other and then gets injected
into the other tiles compute Network and
here this instruction has a source
operand that's that register Matt
operand so it knows where to get this
value from and then you can do the
computation an interesting aspect here
that while you know you've seen
instructions like this just normal set
of instructions here you also have
explicit routing and services that are
executed on the switch processor so the
switch processor here says take the
value that's coming from my processor
and send it East so it's it each
processor can send values east west
north or south so you can go to the tile
above it tile below it Kyle to the left
of it or tile to the right of it and so
sending east sends it along this wire
here and then this particular switch
processor says get a value from the
Westport and send it to my processor now
you could have had here this processor
could say this value is not for me so I
want to just pass it through to some
other processor so you can pass it from
the Westport at a South port orchard
north port or just pass it through
laterally to the other eastport so just
allows you to essentially just have an
on-chip network and an operand you can
imagine having an operand that has a
data packet and a header that says I'm
going to tile 10 and the switches know
which way to send it but interesting
aspect here is that the compiler
actually orchestrates the communication
so you don't need that extra header that
says I'm going to pile 10 you just have
to generate a schedule of how to write
that data through so we'll get into what
that means for the compiler in terms of
that added complexity and so
communication on multi-core which is
expensive for the following reasons and
this is really sort of going to contrast
or it's going to put the scale operand
network and it's slightly more
perspective but first so how do you
communicate between multicores on the
cell you have disease EG må transfers
from one SPE to another you can't really
ship an operon a single value so if I
write a value X and i want to send x
from one spe to another can't really do
that very efficiently right and so this
is essentially contrast
thing between multi-core processors that
largely exists today and the raw
processor so we've shown you to an
empirical form on quantitative
analytical model for communication cause
before in earlier slides this is sort of
an illustration of that concept so if i
have a processor that's talking to
another you know that value has to
travel across some network and there's
some transport costs associated with
that but there's also some added
complexity so there are lots of terms if
you remember in a really big equation
i've shown before you have some some
overhead in terms of packaging the data
and you have some overhead in terms of
unpacking the data so what does that
look well there are two components we're
going to break this down to descend
occupancy in send latency and let's talk
about each of those and similarly on the
receipt side you have the receiver
latency and receive occupancy so bear in
mind you know this is a lifetime of a
message essentially has to flow through
these five components it has to go
through the occupancy stage then there's
received descend latency transport
receive Lansing and receive occupancy
before you can actually use it to
compute on so what are some things that
you do here well lets you know things
that you've done on cell for getting DMA
transfers to work you have to figure out
who the destination is what is the value
maybe you have an idea so here with it
atag things with that sort then you have
to essentially inject that message into
the network so there's some latency
associated with that maybe you're you
know if on cell you have a DMA engine
but if you're and which essentially
hides this latency for you because you
can essentially just send the message to
the EMA write it into its cue and you
can essentially forget about it unless
it's stalled because the MA list is full
on the received I you sort of have a
similar thing you have to get the
network to inject that value into the
processor and then you have to be
packaged at demultiplex it in put it
into some form that you can actually use
to operate on it so this five tuple
gives us a way of sort of characterizing
the community
occasion patterns on different
architectures so I can contrast for
example raw vs as traditional
microprocessor so this is a traditional
superscalar traditional superscalar
essentially has all the sophisticated
circuitry that allows you to essentially
bypass networks you can have an operand
directly flowing to another ALU through
all these and N squared wires in the
crossbar and a lot of dynamic scheduling
is going on so it really has not
officially and see you're not sending
you're not doing any packaging of the
operands your transport cost is
essentially completely hidden you have
no complexity on receipt side so it's
really efficient so this is essentially
what you want to get to this kind of 52
full but as we saw before it's really
not scalable because wire complexity
glows it's N squared and cubed it's not
good from an energy efficient point of
view scalable multiprocessors is on chip
multiprocessors sort of more indicative
of things that you have today have this
kind of five tuple where you have you
know about 16 cycles just to get a
message out if you know roughly three
cycles or so to transport message maybe
this is being done through a shared
cache which is how a lot of architecture
sort of communicate between processors
today and you have to sort of
demultiplex the the message on the
receive side so that I add some leniency
in raw because you have these memory
mapped registers on the inputs on the
output side you really can knock down
the send the complexity from the sense
I'd in terms of the occupancy and
delancey 20 and you just write the value
to the register it looks like a normal
register right but it magically appears
on the network and then from one tile to
another it's one cycle to ship a value
across that one link from one switch
processor to the other as long as it's
near knee open your neighbor and then
two cycles to sort of inject the network
into the top processor and then you're
ready to use it so in this space where
would you put cell is the question
anybody with any ideas
what would the communication kind of
look like on cell
okay so you have to do explicit sends
and receives those this man so can we
get rid of this stage on cell which is
essentially saying packaging up my
message and it's not right because you
have to essentially say where the DMA
transfer is going to go to which region
of memory so you're building these
control blocks right and then assembly
is he here is roughly zero because you
have a DMA processor which allows you
that kind of concurrency between
communication and computation so you can
hide essentially that part of the
transport that part of communication
costs your transport costs here you have
this really massive bandwidth and this
really high bandwidth interconnect on
the chip so this makes it reasonably
fast but it's still a few few cycles you
know your neighbor yeah 100 cycles to go
near neighbor communication because
you're still so you don't have that fast
mechanism of being able to send things
point to point you're putting things on
bus and sort of there's some complexity
there on the receive side you have the
same kind of complexity that you had on
since I'd you have to know that a
message is coming down in different ways
and then you have to take that message
and right into your local store which
also adds some overhead in terms of the
communication costs so so cell would
probably be somewhere up here I would
imagine I didn't have a chance to get
the numbers if I do I'll update the
slide later on okay so that's
essentially brief insight into the rod
yeah the scalable processor
so these are from Michael Taylor's
thesis so I believe what he's done years
just looked at some existing micro
processors and essentially benchmark
communication latency from one processor
to another that's in fact how you you
know a lot of these multiprocessors
today have shared captures either at l1
I'm more so now it's l2 so you have L
ones are dedicated different processors
but you still have to go through memory
to communicate great so raw paralyzing
compiler yet another question so two
related questions so so bra has surprise
rob has pretty well optimized nearest
neighbor communication as we know from
we know from for example rents and rec
rents rule in heuristic in intellectual
engineering about the number of wires in
it for viewing area is that it's between
zero call these roughly the minimum for
a good sized circuit is proportional to
the perimeter you're roughly the square
root of area and it goes ranges from
there to not not officially Harrison
community within 23
like three to the three halves power I
think perhaps now so the two thirds yeah
two thirds power so the area to the one
half power or area to two-thirds power
so that rents rule says the number of
wires is roughly roughly in that area
and so that sort of pushes that so the
mid room you need is sort of your super
communication and often often you need
more like that you're from the FPGA
experience that that yours neighbor
communication is not it's good to have
more than genera and then often long
wires yeah was across the ship certainly
extremely high so I'm going to actually
show you an example of where nearest
neighbor is good but you might also want
some global mechanism for control
orchestration for example so not just
I'm not sure just for control the
broadcast for arbitrary board that for
the computation use not just with a
shift so all right okay like wires
you're scaling out to ops for ops fewer
fewer wires yeah sorry in fact what you
what I think is going to happen is a lot
of these chip design is going to be
hierarchical right you have some really
global type communication at the highest
level and then as you get within each
one of the processors then you see
things at the lowest level something
that looks like bra so you can build
sort of a hierarchy of communication
stages that allow you to sort of solve
that problem but all of that adds
complexity right first you have to solve
the problem of how do you paralyzed for
just a fixed number of cores and then
figure out the communications once we
sort of understand how to do that well
with a nice programming model and you
sort of build higher
is not as strange it might give you a
nice fallback right it might save you in
cases where there are things that are
hard to do but there are some issues in
the last two last to the second to the
last three slides we'll talk about an
example of where that might be the case
yes sir I is being touched or simple
entitled i guess one of the selling
points it was a he cuts down on the
engineering effort absolutely i'm here
this was done you know million gates in
in house fires so did she seem so
company like intel has a ridiculous
number of Engineers and to get a
competitive edge who do you want to
apply the question is where might you
apply more engineer thank you that's the
million-dollar question that everybody
is sleeping it in some sense if they
thought they can act like more and more
engineering and hear this Billy complex
for scalars and then you get there but
that's not a big panel for it and so I
think there's still a lot of things that
if raw leading to the custom illus a few
custom invasive process so adding
intel-based like that they'd be a lot of
Engineers doing each of these components
fine grain view and they can get lot
more performance less power and so I do
I mean depending on what you look one
size is not everything
repeatability can be helpful for it so
while it makes it easier which I know
process I don't think it will complexity
mean for a lot of integration and the
key thing is start something simple and
as you go on people have no income just
obviously moving to me and you know part
of the pleasure might be going to not
making all those cars it's okay so raw
pushes a lot of the complexity into the
compiler in that pilot now has to do at
least few things it has to distribute
instructions you know you have a single
program and you have to figure out how
to paralyze it across multiple pours but
not only that because you have this
skill up right network you have to
figure out how two different cores have
to talk to each other so you have to
essentially generate a schedule for the
switch processors as well so I'm going
to talk a little bit about the raw
parallelizing compiler and this is
different from the stream it paralyzing
compiler which really talks about the
different program as an input using a
different language this is work that was
again done here at MIT by walter lee who
graduated two years ago well you have a
sequential program you inject it into
rossi see you're all c compiler and you
get fine-grained orchestrated parallel
execution and what the compiler does is
worry about data distribution just like
you have to do on cell in terms of which
memory goes into which local store you
know which computation operates on the
rock and pilot is to worry about which
computation operates on which data
element and can you put that data at the
right caches for each of different tiles
instruction distribution so the way this
compiler essentially gets parallelism
it's going to look at instruction level
parallelism in your application and it's
going to divide that up among the
different cores and then the last step
is to coordination of communication and
control flow so i'm just going to
briefly step through each one of those
so the data distribution really has
essentially trying to solve the problem
of locality you have two instructions
load into r1 from some address and then
you're adding all one
fermenting that value it might write
impact for later on so where would you
put these two instructions so to exploit
the locality then you want sort of the
data if the data is here then you want
these two instructions to be on this
path if the data is here then you want
these two instructions to be on this
file because it doesn't help you to have
the data here and instructions here is
what do you have to do in that case you
have to send a message that says sending
you this data and you have to wait for
it to come in and then you have to
operate on it and then maybe you have to
write it back so the compiler sort of
worries about the data distribution it
applies some data analysis a lot of the
things that you saw in Simone's lecture
on classic paralyzation technology sort
of figure out data dependencies and then
they can figure I hadn't split up the
data across the different cores and do
some other work done by other students
in the group sort of tried to address
this problem the instruction
distribution is perhaps as complicated
and interesting and hear what's going on
is let's say you have a base block so
you take your sequential program you
figure out you know which what are the
different basic blocks of computation
that you have and within the base block
you have lots of instructions so each
one of these green boxes is particular
instruction and what you're seeing these
arrows here that connect the edges are
operated that you have to exchange so
you might have and this is an add
instruction requires value come in from
here multiply instructor a construction
requires values coming in from different
areas so how would you distribute this
across number of cores or across number
of tiles I need any ideas here so you
can look for for example some chains
that are not interconnected so you can
look for clusters that you can use and
say ok well I see no edges here so maybe
I can put this on one tile and then
maybe I can put some of these
instructions on another tile because
sort of the communication flow is local
so maybe one strategy might be look for
longest sustained so you can keep the
communication flow and then you apply
sort of
and make an algorithm sort of come up
with a number of clusters well something
like that does happen and keep in mind
from the lectures we talked about the
paralyzing compiler is you have to worry
about parallel universes communication
so more you distribute things the more
communication you have to get right so
here what's showing what i'm showing is
sort of color mapping from the original
instructions in the base block to the
same instructions but now each color
essentially represents a different
cluster or essentially code that i would
mapped a different thread and so blue is
one thread yellow is another green is
another red purple and so on but I have
to worry about sort of communication
between the different colors because
they're essentially two different
threads are going to run on two
different processors or two different
tiles so those errors that are
highlighted in sort of dark black our
communication edges I have to explicitly
send the operands around right so then I
might look at the granularity what is my
communication cost but is my computation
cause and I want to worry about load
balancing as we saw a load balancing can
sort of give you can better make use of
your architecture and give you better
utilization better throughput so it
might essentially say it doesn't it's
not worthwhile sort of have DS running
on a different tile because there's a
lot of communication going on so maybe I
don't want to fuse those together keep
local the communication local and
essentially eliminate costly
communication so there are different
heuristics that you can apply you can
use that five to bowl you can use your
wrist expand on the 52 will determine
one is profitable to break things up and
when it's not and then you have to worry
about placement right so you don't quite
have this in cell in that you create
these SPE threads and they can run on
any SPE in the rock compiler you can
actually exploit the spatial
characteristics of the chip and the
point-to-point communication network to
say i want to put these two threads on
tile 1 and tile to wear tie one entitled
to are adjacent to each other because i
have a well-defined communication
pattern that i'm going to use and map to
the communication network on the chip to
get really fast really low latency so
you can take each one
these colors place it on a different
pile and now you have these wires are
going across these tiles which
essentially represent communication but
now Paula has to worry about oh I have
to essentially send these on fixed
routes there's no arbitrary
communication mechanism so if there's
data going from this tile to this tile
actually has to be routed through a
network and that might mean getting
routed through somebody else's tile so
the next stage would be communication
coordination you have to figure out
which which you need to go to you know
and what do you do to get that out
printer right switch which then gets it
your night processor so here there sir I
believe do your stick is to do dimension
order routing so you send along the X
dimension and and then the Y dimension I
might have those remember and then
finally now you figure out you can
communication patterns you figure out
your instructions you do some
instruction scheduling and what you can
do here because the communication
patterns are static you've split up your
instructions you know when you need to
ship data around and how you can
guarantee deadlock freedom by carefully
ordering your send and receive pairs so
what you see here you know every time
you see it an instruction that needs to
strip an offer and around there's
equivalent of a route instruction that
says east west north south there's an
equivalent route instruction on the
other processors and that allows you to
essentially analyze code and say okay
I've laid these things are carefully
have orchestrated my send and receive
pairs so i can guarantee for example
there are no overlapping routes or that
there are no deadlox because one is
trying to ship to the other while the
others also trying to ship a block on
the shared network link and finally you
have the code representation so this is
where you package things up into object
files and to essentially things like
threads and then you can compile them
and run them now so that question that
would that was posed earlier well
there's one thing we haven't talked
about and that's branching this is a
sequential program it has it excuse
branches now I have this loop that I've
sort of split up across number of tiles
how do I know who's going to do
branch and if one tile is doing the
branch how does it communicate with
everybody else or if I'm going to repeat
the branch on every tile does that mean
I'm redoing too much computation on
every other tile so control coordination
is actually quite an interesting aspect
of adds another interesting aspect to
sort of the parallelization for raw and
so what you have to do is figure out
that there are 22 different ways you can
do it because you have no mechanism for
a global message on on Raw you can't say
i've taken a branch everybody go to this
program counter you essentially have to
send either the branch result so one
tile can do the comparison it calculates
the condition and then it has to
communicate X to each of the different
branches to each of different tiles or
every tile has to essentially just
replicate the control flow and redo the
computation so every tile figures out
what is the condition what are the
conditions for the branch it they
redundantly do that computation then
they can all branch at the same time at
different times so that gives you two
ways of sort of doing branching if each
high-low sort of doing its own control
flow calculation then they can
essentially branch at different times
but if they're all going to wait for the
result that compared and essentially
gives you points where you have to
synchronize everybody's going to wait
for the results of the branch but the
latency could be different right because
if I'm sending the branch condition to
one tile versus another tile and if
one's closer than the other then the
branch is closer to me the tile is
closer to me we'll take that branch
earlier in time so you get a sort of the
effect of global asynchronous branching
in either case is there any sense ok 0
since summary draw the role architecture
is really tiled microprocessor it
incorporates sort of the best elements
from super scalars in terms of a really
low latency communication network
between tiles which really cuts down on
the communication costs as we saw and is
probably your you've been learning
communication is really an expensive
part of parallelization on existing
multi-core chips and it's also getting
sort of the scalability of multicores in
terms of explicit parallelism
it also gives you implicit parallelism
because the networks are pipeline and
they can give you flow control so you're
trying to get to the point where you
have a tile processor with a skillet
operating network that allows you to
sort of do communication with a very low
cost and you know it might be the case
in the future that these chips will
essentially be you know more complex
architectures will sit on top of you so
you'll do this you'll lose these as
fundamental building blocks and it's you
know there was a the 80 chip multi-core
from Intel there have been rumors that
that might actually be something like a
graphics processor that has something
like the scale outlined network because
you could communicate with a very fast
with very low latency between tiles and
in that article which came out a few
months ago the first time I think that I
had seen piled architectures used in in
literature or in publications so I think
you sort of see more of these kinds of
design patterns appear has people sort
of scale out to more than 200 448 cores
and so on where you can still
communicate reasonably well with caches
and that's all I prepared today any
other questions and then we'll so people
who've contributed to the Ralph I bet a
lot of students is led by not a smart
idea you like it giving you dented view
of what happen
kind of what it relates to and I think
there's some relationship so what you
guys have been doing but take it too
much finally in peace whereas in said of
course the messages has to be large you
can do a lot of pasta and stuff but in
raw we try to do much more five days
when I talk about next victim filter
using something special by itself ich
hab protection but 30 long wires with
one there's no [ __ ] that you have this
you have this network user has no hardly
so that we're actually park NJ ignore it
if the way you can do is you can
actually in modern processors you look
at blue blazer the cop is not seen this
club cheetah so since there's no long
why you can actually carry the clock
with the data and so in global well that
the switching here it happen our sinks
which in here but since there's no plate
wire connecting leasing that's okay so
so you can deal with club today so it's
not going to be [ __ ] drift along as
Peters yeah that's what I mean one end
of the process is a clock is happening
at the global instant time differently
from at the end of the course but since
there's no body requires also go through
that to DP it's a cross drift between
the respect of free distribution and
then since the wires also kind of go in
the three we can be drink drink meaning
taking at different rates not just no
other it is basically I know there is
right when it is the rescue in giving
the
it's going to stocks cute going between
there so you see don't eat synchronizers
between the different I'll see so we
don't we learning tonight because files
are no collect if the clock between
those tiles dropped between two things
that communicates are close enough that
it fits within the cycle but but but for
example if you get it to very far away
branches of a tree and then if you try
to communicate then you have a problem
other thing is whether when the tree
goes here even those two different
branches it has a similar chief going
down so you can come in press across so
there are all these things I mean model
poses really deal with these kind of
tools that you can eat a problem occurs
ways if you have try to connect directly
for for other end of a branch something
that gets dropped there something that
clock it at a very early another branch
if you try to connect those two then
there might be skew might be too long
that you can get in trouble okay I worry
about this this is what I mean the
doctor egos in the office yes the first
my head was in the a mesh obviously the
processors in the middle I have further
tips guy devices to main memory
what you see happening we'll get to
larger market processors are just put
forward more vocal around the tile and
fulton taking it or go to add memory bus
is offering to the combination of both
right so in not just memory i/o devices
if you're doing I oh then you might want
to be placed at a part of chip that has
direct access to an i/o device are very
close it also comes up in case of the
communication orchestration so if this
guy is doing the branch and you want him
essentially centrally located so the
good the best patterns for allocating
things is essentially across it's like a
plus sign where it branches in the
middle but there's no freedom uniform by
everybody equally bad and then a lot of
times people have done that too as they
don't believe I simple model inventory
equal it is really bad oh you try to
make advantage of closeness and stuff
with it so you can't have both ways and
so when you're trying to make very very
very close and fast access and you're
doing by basically making their other
parts to have less resources less access
on other hand there are a lot of people
that might be more for pollution things
that for example this thing called free
space laser so what that does is you put
a mirror on top of the pile give it to
top of the processor and each of these
you can embed a small LED receiver and
transmitter into the chip so basically
if you wanna communicate somehow just
bounce a laser on top of that and get it
to the right side so there are a lot of
these exotic things can might be able to
solve this thing technical problem but
in some case we'd of light I don't think
any engineers figure out how to break
speed of light unless of course people
go with quantum computing and stuff like
that so so I mean the key thing is you
have resources your resource limitation
is completely with it getting nice
uniformity as a cost yeah how my hands
of sailors their groups here at MIT who
are working in
optical networks in the third dimension
you have Kyle chip plus an optical
network from the third dimension allows
you to do things like but not much more
efficient okay yeah so here you take a
smaller